[Music]
so that there are several different
areas which I work but essentially I'm
sculptor so I sculpt the prosthetics or
the fake bodies or whatever happens to
come through the door then I'm on set
I usually go on set and you apply the
prosthetic for the actor of go on set
when they film and do any touch-up
necessary on set as part of the shoot
gosh well it all began a long time okay
more than 25 years ago and it was really
a hobby it's very difficult at the time
and these sort of mid-80s to find out
very much about it and I was inspired by
some magazines I bought sitting in magic
magazine I found in an old comic shop
and it showed the process the sculpting
and the mold making and how to make a
little latex ask and I thought that look
like fun so I kind of had to go myself
really and found the materials but
because it's so me at the time it was
such a big thing in America wasn't done
over here so much it was really
difficult to get hold of any products or
anything so it took me a lot of research
I know a lot of people and kind of my
age did a similar thing where he went to
the library and you kept renewing the
same book from the library because you
couldn't actually buy it this country so
kind of went through that process until
eventually I was producing work and I
went to art school is the kind of book
tonic the idea of doing it as a career
and I went to art school and then I did
some vocational training and
hairdressing and makeup and essentially
I got apprenticeship that company called
in regeneration in the late 80s I think
the very first thing I worked on was
small indie film called I bought the
vampire motorcycle which was essentially
that about motorcycle hit that went way
and killing people and sucking their
blood to save its fuel tank so that was
like some very funny thing to work on
and then quite a big movie for the time
called Nightbreed which is earned
directed by and written by Clive Barker
who wrote Hellraiser and image animation
at the time were quite big company and I
think we had a big crew on that about
7080 people working on it all sorts of
weird and wonderful guilty creatures and
monsters for that and that was really
where I sort of came from coming in and
making a tea and making blood to
eventually sculpting some stuff painting
pieces going on sex so I had my
apprenticeship really throughout that
that movie I was much more experienced
as a sculptor by the time I went to
Eartha Madame Tussauds and they have a
very specific way of working and their
techniques they use there have been
invaluable for so many of the things
I've done since but they work on a
completely different way to the sort of
creative pathetic makeup effects
industry because what they're doing is
reproducing real life and you really
need to be absolutely accurate in
everything you do you know there's
there's a right and wrong it looks like
Leonardo DiCaprio or it doesn't so
that's a extremely difficult very kind
of precise way of sculpting but the
skills it gives you the ability to be
able to interpret designs if you'll give
them a picture of six tentacles octopus
face creature from sort of one angle you
you learn having worked at two swords
you kind of learn how to read their
photographs and think oh well that looks
like it's behind that and you can sort
of interpret those designs more
accurately I find because I got into it
from it really being a hobby originally
it's a bit like being paid to do your
hobby to some degree I mean it's a very
creative it's a lot problem-solving it's
great to come up with new techniques and
materials in there are so many materials
that we use at the moment and there's
always new ways to do things and so for
me is some of the technical challenges
are great but really it's see it's the
chance to be able to sculpt and paint
and that kind of create these amazing
creatures and
illusions making people cold that make
it really enjoyable so with the advent
of new technologies ATT and CG in
everything we have to be a little more
careful for sure about how our work is
finished and I clean everything needs to
be I think that often when prosthetics
is shot they you can still get away with
quite a lot just by good lighting it
doesn't matter if it's super good HD
with stuff like Game of Thrones is so
mad actually a lot of the Marvel movies
a lot the big action blockbuster movies
now are so graded in the in the post in
post-production that you don't you don't
really is worrying you look at the
quality of HD anything oh my god you're
going to be able to see every single
little brush marconi but by the time
they finish grading things these days it
doesn't you don't you don't notice it I
think there are you know if you're doing
a much more realistic docu style movie
and you've got maybe some old age
makeups in here then that's very tricky
but I think a lot of things are still
shot and film I think filmmakers prefer
the look of film I think they just feel
that it's got more life - it's got more
soul in an ideal world for us and for
actors really a kind of combination of
having real things on set for people to
react to and being able to put like
green where no very does it with a lot
of things on Game of Thrones with the
whites
they've got green costumes on and green
sections missing so in the
post-production they just remove those
areas and so there you can see through
the characters which is great that's a
fantastic of cross-pollination of
there's techniques but it's still really
good for the actors there's something
there to look at something to react to
that is more than a ball on the end of a
stick so hopefully we've still got some
years left in us yet it's always a
mixture of being proud of what you've
created and you know they'll a lot I
mean he's particularly liking is a great
character says everybody that we say
amazing innit but it's quite
nerve-wracking as well because it just
depends how you deal with the small
amount of stress
that something was about to come up and
they're about filming and it's getting
late in the day and you know various
things like the smoke doesn't look right
and this doesn't look right and then
suddenly he you know the only thing they
do something that kind of loosens a
piece and you have to go in there and
touch it out so there is a there was a
small amount of stress involved just in
making sure you're paying attention and
and it's very easy when you have a slow
day to kind of take your eye off the
ball of it and just see how come on
Monday and they thought well they're not
doing anything with it and then suddenly
you look at the monitor and he's they're
doing a massive great close-up and you
have just get in there and you know make
sure you get your moment within before
they start filming so so it's yeah it's
a lot of waiting around and then lots of
really busy periods but depending on how
long the shoot is as well if you're in
for a day it's great fun to go for a
couple of days and you do something like
a freight slash way is there for a
couple days you make a mess eople blood
everywhere and then you leave that's
great now that's got something to do
sometimes when we were filming on Game
of Thrones we were up in this quarry in
Belfast in the rain and the clothes and
for about four three an hour for weeks
every day it can get a bit miserable
with it you know but at the end of the
day you know you were still most of the
still and really happy to be doing what
we do sometimes it is interesting to
look at other people's work and it's
always interesting to look at the
people's work but you don't want to find
that you're drifting all sort of to
influence by somebody whose work you in
my in my and you end up kind of half
copying what they've done I think you
know the best stuff is often completely
original I worked on guardians of the
galaxy years ago with Dave White and you
know the stuff that he and I think Colin
Jill was designing we were brilliant
even the holes of the theme of stuff was
all really quite original and that was a
great project to be involved with
because of that that kind of completely
different makeup look and that's quite
exciting and itself just to be creating
or something it looks you know quite
quite quite unique I think the skills
you need to do this kind of job I mean
are quite varied it depends how focused
you are on any particular area so if you
really really want to sculpt then
obviously going to art school or doing
any sort of sculptural work is perfect
sculpture degrees fine art degrees if
you want to paint then same thing
actually find out painting illustration
anything we are using color so if you
want to be on set then obviously your
your skill as a makeup artist is one big
thing but a lot of that also is a
personality thing how will you relate to
people well I hope your interpersonal
skills are so there that's a very
important part that's just actually
relating to other actors because you can
just work in a workshop and sculpt and
have your headphones on all day and you
know not speak to anyone so it's a real
mix I think we have to do everything is
just yeah you just need to have that
balance have a nice balance of those
skills and patience yeah definitely I
mean I think that's that's - of
sculpting as well sometimes you can't
quite get where you want to go instantly
and you do have to work at it and work
at it and I mean I think from the way I
came into it from actually having to
find out a lot of stuff myself you you
you become quite dogged and sort
determined to get something until you
get what you want out of it and that's a
useful skill for the industry generally
I think anyone who works in the film
industry you do need to be quite am
persistent
there are lots of schools now that teach
prosthetics and makeup effects and my
advice would be really to look at the
syllabus of the schools and see what
techniques they teach there are some
really really good books that are quite
cheap and Deborah Nietzsche's book is
good it just touches on most of the
materials most of the techniques of
prosthetics and makeup effects use you
know it's only a few
and a lot of people still come into it
by being a partly self-taught but it's I
think it is probably so much faster now
to go through uni but you have to come
out realizing that you don't act just
because you've learned modern techniques
that's not it you don't know it all now
you need to still plenty to learn and so
much of it is beyond just filling a mold
or pouring something you know there are
lots of other educate things that
workshops and I've been on set and just
being sociable and all those sort of
aspects of along with any job really but
yeah I mean certainly check out your
school and compare it don't be afraid to
compare it don't be afraid to sign up
and or find out what the teachers have
done because you know if you're paying
to go to school then you really want to
get as good as education as you can
issue as you can as you can
[Music]